growing worries about the economy are
hitting stocks and the housing market
hard the dow jones industrial average
fell below 30 thousand yesterday for the
first time in 17 months the s p 500 and
nasdaq also dropped and with the fed
raising interest rates again average
long-term mortgage rates saw their
biggest one-week jump in 35 years chris
vancleave is in st louis this morning to
show how that affects the once red hot
red hot i should say housing market
chris good morning
well good morning michelle we're under
threatening skies here in st louis and
you could say the same for the housing
market with inflation and those soaring
interest rates cooling the market here
in st louis pending home sales were down
nearly 10 percent in may compared to a
year ago and there are parts of the
country where property values are
actually falling
cheryl leslie is house hunting in fort
worth texas hoping to move closer to her
grandkids this is cute so i'm looking
now so that when the prices come down
just a tad i'll be able to know exactly
what i need and what i want and where to
go but as interest rates surge past 6
percent hitting their highest point
since 2008 an estimated 18 million
households who would have qualified for
a mortgage in january are essentially
frozen out of the market no longer
eligible for that loan
and those who can still afford to buy a
typical new mortgage payment has spiked
52 percent over the last six months the
market's going to change dramatically
mark zandy is moody analytics chief
economist we will see house price growth
the level off here and we'll see some
price declines in some of the more
juiced up markets across the country
particularly and in my mind that's a
correction when house prices start to go
lower mortgage applications are down
more than 15 percent compared to 2021
dropping 5 percent in may alone that's
prompting nearly one in five sellers to
drop their price this week realty
company redfin announced it would cut
hundreds of jobs because of the slowing
housing market the housing market is in
a downturn right now it's cyclical and
it just doesn't support the number of
employees we have before this home in
arlington texas has been on the market
for 28 days not selling even after the
price was dropped only a few people came
to the open house six bedroom five and a
half it's 42 82 square feet
realtor tina jason says that's a marked
change
this home
i imagine that six months ago would have
sold very quickly like would not have
been on the on the market two weeks
later no
now there is still more demand than
supply for homes so you can't call it a
buyer's market yet but even in red hot
dallas the compass realty agent that's
working with cheryl in our story there
is starting to tell sellers not to
expect a bidding war especially if it's
a house that needs work nate
chris thank you